Toyota used to be ahead of its time.
When General Motors didn’t think
there was a market for small cars,
Toyota introduced small, compact cars
to America beginning in the fifties,
and eventually, overtook GM to
become the world’s largest automaker.
Research firms have rated
Toyota and its luxury line Lexus
among the top automotive brands for years.
However, the glory days may be over.
Like other automakers, Toyota struggled
during the pandemic with chip shortages.
In the fall of 2021 - it made 40% fewer cars
and trucks as a result of supply chain issues.
But the problems may not end with the pandemic.
On top of everything else, Toyota’s
progress toward developing electric
vehicles has been incredibly slow.
It still does not have a pure electric vehicle
on the road, those powered only by batteries.
It does have one in the pipeline.
The yet-to-be-released bZ4X was
only revealed in the fall of 2021.
Toyota is lagging behind despite having promising
plans for the clean energy
car market two decades ago.
Toyota wowed the world with the first
commercial hybrid, the Prius, in 1997.
Hybrids combine gas engines with electric motors
so they use less fuel than
traditional gasoline vehicles.
And then, Toyota started producing an electric
RAV4 in 2012 - the world’s only
all-electric SUV at the time.
To make it happen, it partnered with
a little California car company.
Tesla.
Toyota’s president was blown
away by Tesla’s roadster.
Akio Toyoda said he felt
“...the wind of the future.”
You can put the full quote on-screen: “To put it
simply, I felt the wind, the wind of the future.”
The two companies even
shared a factory for a while.
However, Toyota discontinued the RAV4 EV
after only two years. It had a limited
customer base as it was sold only in California,
and there were issues with long charging times.
Toyota and Tesla parted ways
in 2014 and became rivals.
Toyota’s president has taken shots at Elon Musk
as recently as two years ago - saying Tesla
may have a recipe but it lacks a kitchen
and a chef - which Toyota argues it has.
Tesla and Toyota have polar
opposite EV strategies.
Tesla has focused solely on developing
electric vehicles that are battery-powered,
known as Battery Electric Vehicles (BEVs).
Toyota has chosen to focus on three other types of
electrified vehicles that are NOT purely electric.
Hybrids, plug-in hybrids which can be
plugged in to extend driving range,
and hydrogen-powered fuel-cell cars which Elon
Musk has dismissed as “fool-cell” vehicles.
Fuel cell vehicles use hydrogen gas which
mixes with oxygen to produce electricity.
Musk has said it’s difficult to
make hydrogen and store it in a car.
Toyota offers one hydrogen model, the Mirai,
but seems to have a special thing for hybrids
and plug-in hybrids, which made up basically
all of its half a million electrified
vehicles sales in North America in 2021.
Although plug-in hybrids can be powered
by battery they can’t travel very far
without relying on the gas engine. The Prius Prime
can only go a mere 25 miles or 40 km in EV mode.
Some see hybrids as a stepping stone for those who
aren’t quite ready to make the
leap to a pure electric vehicle.
However, the future appears to be all-electric.
Battery electric vehicles are
outselling plug-in hybrids,
according to data compiled by
the International Energy Agency.
And by the way, this was tabulated before
the insane prices currently
hurting drivers at the pumps.
So, why has Toyota been so reluctant
to embrace battery-electric cars?
In 2020, Toyota’s president Akio Toyoda
said it’s too early to focus solely on
battery-powered electric vehicles…in response
to his country’s push to ban gas-powered cars.
The grandson of Toyota’s founder argued
Japan would run out of electricity in
the summertime if all cars ran on electric power
and pointed out upgrading infrastructure
would cost hundreds of billions of dollars.
It’s true that transitioning to a 100% electric
vehicle fleet will require billions of dollars
of investment in the grid - one study
put it at up to $125 billion for the U.S.
But that may be inevitable.
Shuli Goodman of the Linux Foundation project
LF Energy said to the Washington Post,
“The grid of the future isn’t going to be
a grid at all. It will be more like the
Internet,”...with power generation happening
all over the place. “Something like a forest.”
Advocates of EVs are also pushing
renewable energy to charge an electric car.
And charging at night when
electricity demand is lower.
But expanding the grid isn’t the only
issue concerning the head of Toyota.
Akio Toyoda has said going all-in on
EVs in Japan could cost millions of
jobs. Battery-electric vehicles have fewer
parts and require fewer laborers to make.
EVs would also shrink the
third-party supplier ecosystem.
Although it seems Toyota is finally
pivoting toward EVs as it plans to
introduce 30 all-electric models
by 2030 - looks can be deceiving.
The company is still not
abandoning its love of hybrids!
Out of the 8 million electrified vehicles Toyota
hopes to sell by 2030, only 3.5 million will
be purely electric - a far cry from the 20
million Tesla aims to sell annually by 2030.
And we look at the specs of Toyota’s upcoming
bZ4X - it’s less impressive than a Tesla.
Delivering less range and taking more time to
go zero to 60 miles an hour
than any of Tesla’s models.
But of course, price matters. We don’t yet
know what Toyota’s electric SUV will cost
and if it will be significantly less than a Tesla.
Some say Tesla is the Apple of cars.
When Nokia, Ericsson, and Motorola
all missed the smartphone revolution,
they never caught up to Apple.
Toyota could find itself in the same boat
if it remains reluctant to go
all-in on battery-powered EVs.
More and more EVs are being sold every year.
If you’d like to find the next big trend,
or big idea, my sponsor Trends can help.
Trends sends you emerging business
trends months before they pop up,
saving you research and
thousands of dollars in testing.
For example, research from Trends currently shows
home theaters are increasingly becoming popular
as people anticipate spending more
time at home even post-pandemic.
When Trends uncovered that the indoor
plant business was about to bloom,
a Trends member took note, got valuable
advice from the Trends community made up
of thousands of ambitious business builders,
and raised $1.5 million in funding in 40 days.
If you’d like to start finding your
next great idea and growing a business,
you can take advantage of a special
offer you can only get on my channel.
To start your 7-day trial today go to
Trends.co/newsthink. That’s Trends.co/newsthink
to start your 7-day trial for just $1. The
link is in my description and pinned comment.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.